This is a chart of the gender pay gap
in developed economies.
In the US, women are paid
17% less than men.
And in Japan, 22%.
On the other end,
there's Iceland...
where the pay gap is around 10%.
It's one of the few countries in the world
where women are paid
almost as much as men.
But that wasn't the case
about 50 years ago.
In 1975, the gender pay gap
in the US
was 37%.
Japan was 42%...
and Iceland was at 40%.
So how did it go from here... to here?
To figure that out, you have to
take a look
at what happened
on this day in 1975.
This idea was to show...
that we could bring
society to a standstill.
If we were not there,
nothing was done.
We expected a lot of women to
show up at the demonstration,
But not in our wildest
dreams did we expect this.
This is the story of how
Icelandic women
shut down their country
and changed it forever.
Iceland gained independence
from Denmark
and became a parliamentary democracy
in 1944.
“Iceland separated from Denmark
and regained full self-government.”
The conservative Independence Party
became the strongest political force
in the country
and held the position of Prime Minister
for almost 20 years.
Under this party's leadership
policies that enforced gender inequity
were widespread...
especially in the workplace.
By the 70s, women made up
the majority
of poorly paid, undervalued jobs...
and were forced out of the labor market
to work at home.
In response to decades of conservative policies
a new women's group called
The Redstockings
took radical steps to demand equal rights.
Like when they crowned a cow
at the Young Miss Iceland pageant
to bring attention to unfair
beauty standards.
And crucified a doll
dressed like a housewife
to protest women's domestic labor.
It is a very active group.
A bit anarchistic.
This is Elisabet Gunnarsdottir
a founding member of the Redstockings.
We felt that there
were so many
aspects of our lives that
hadn't been discussed,
that had stayed the same
for such a long time.
Workplace inequity was a big issue
Elisabet and the Redstockings
wanted to challenge
and they took to the streets
to draw attention to it.
In the first of May
demonstration in 1970,
We carried a big statue
on our shoulders.
And we got it from a play
that had been put up
in Reykjavík that winter,
about women going on strike.
But to make an impact, they wanted
a full blown strike.
And that was going to be complicated...
because organizing a strike
outside of trade unions
and employers associations
was illegal in Iceland.
So the Redstockings who weren't
part of either group
couldn't act on their idea.
Until 1975
when the United Nations kicked off...
“International Women's Year.”
“I would like to welcome you all
to this really historic event.”
This was the first global conference
dedicated to women's issues.
“Women form part of
virtually every delegation.”
And governments around the world
planned events to address
gender discrimination.
In Iceland, the Prime Minister's
office selected
representatives from different
women's associations
across the country to make preparations.
The committee was politically diverse.
It included teachers, single mothers
conservatives, and liberals like
the Redstockings...
to make sure the event reflected
the views of women across Iceland.
The Redstockings took this opportunity
to propose that a women strike
against the gender pay gap
was the best way to mark
International Women's Year.
The conservative women’s associations
found the idea far too radical.
But the Redstockings believed
in the strike.
So they pushed for one and slowly
got some members on board.
But overall, the committee was reluctant...
until they heard...
A woman around 70,
she was from a
center political party,
from the old feminists.
And she came to the podium and said,
“Strike? Is that what you don't like?”
“Why don't you then
call it just a day off?”
So that's what they did.
The committee picked a day
when women would collectively refuse
to work at home and in the office
to prove their economic value.
And they called it a day off
or “kvennafrí”.
They only had three months to prepare.
So the Redstockings and
the rest of the committee
immediately mobilized multiple
labor unions and women's organizations
the country to plan, fundraise, and
spread the word about kvennafrí.
The political parties used their own platform
to talk to their women.
There were all kinds of women from diverse...
political and social groups.
And we worked very well together,
all of us.
They wrote hundreds of letters
to women across the country
and called as many households
as they could
in Iceland's phone book
to spread the word.
They wrote articles,
did radio interviews...
[in Icelandic] “The goal is for women from
all over the country
to participate in this women’s holiday.
Designed fliers and organized meetings
late into the night
to make sure that kvennafrí
was a success.
Some men were foolish enough
to threaten women,
threaten their employees...
and that didn't go down well.
On October 24th, 1975...
90% of Icelandic women
refused to work at home
and in the office.
An estimated 25,000 women
took to the streets in Reykjavik alone...
to give speeches and sing
about women's rights.
There is even a vinyl of recorded songs
sung by the Redstockings
from kvennafrí.
[singing in Icelandic]
But dare I, want I, can I?
Yes, I dare, can, and want.
So many women refused to work that day
that Iceland shut down.
Without women
the telephone system crashed
without switchboard operators
newspapers couldn't publish
without type setters.
The national airline canceled flights
because there were no stewardesses.
And preschools across the country
shut down.
Women's absence was felt in the home, too.
Without domestic labor that
Icelandic women carried out...
there was no childcare.
so men had to stay home or
bring their children to work.
It was this cooperation across
politics and classes and...
and housewives and women
working outside the home.
It was a celebration.
The impact of kvennafrí was felt
across the country.
After the day off, Iceland passed its first
Gender Equality Act
and officially banned wage discrimination
on the basis of gender.
Equal rights of women were added
to the Constitution
and women's representation
in Parliament rose too.
In 1980, Iecland elected
its first female leader
and the world's first woman president
to be elected democratically.
Something she insisted wouldn't
have been possible
without kvennafrí.
No country in the world
has completely closed
its gender pay gap.
Iceland still has some work to do too.
But the country's quick progress
is a sign
that closing the gap is possible.
Demonstrations like kvennafrí
might not work in the same way
in other countries...
but its success shows us what happens
when a country unites...
politically and socially to get closer
to equality.
Kvennafrí didn't stop in 1975.
There was one organized
in 1985, 2005
2010, 2016, and 2018.
The event has tackled everything
from reproductive issues
like abortion rights to the ongoing
gender pay gap in Iceland.
But one of my favorite pieces
of history from this story
is that you can actually listen
to the original song sung
on the 1975 day off
off on Spotify.
Which includes song sung by
the Redstockings.
The link is in the description down below.
Thanks again for watching
this episode of Missing Chapter
and we can't wait to see you
in the next one.
Till next time.